[Music]
I was going to talk about this dink dink
dunk coin or whatever oh we're gonna get
we're gonna talk about crypto I watched
the idubbbz video so good so hilarious
because idubbz wasn't even like
you know
we're used to
I feel like idubbbz in previous videos
he's got it there's a bit it's not like
composure but it's very pointed that's
the word I'm looking for it's like he
knows what he wants to say and that's
how I picture idubbbz in my mind it's
like he he has points he's gonna make
and like he's gonna do it in a very like
precise manner yeah this [ __ ] had me
laughing because
he's just so legitimately so angry yeah
oh I laughed and more importantly it
like made me feel good because I'm like
you know sometimes I see things and I
feel
compelled to like put my thoughts in a
concise way and like watching Ian do
this [ __ ] I was like no
it is it is not it's not dumb it's not
like yeah it's not cheap to see
something like this and to be so [ __ ]
furious yeah go to the middle or yeah
maybe right there yeah play it
they actually think that everyone's a
[ __ ] idiot they think that everyone's
an idiot no staking oh thank goodness I
don't have to stake it you're ah I want
um yeah yep yep my inner Greg Paul is
coming up
someone right now I wanna
here's a tweet from Logan my inner Greg
Paul
ridiculous [ __ ] coin I've ever seen the
deposit it is it is [ __ ] crazy though
his video that he did about it it's just
like so infuriating and then Mike's
video yeah oh where it's like even just
like he adds that layer of like sarcasm
on top and it's like bro it's like this
doesn't change the fact that you're
scamming your fans yeah it's the same
[ __ ] as the face [ __ ] yeah it's the
exact same [ __ ]
I don't get how anyone doesn't look past
this how do you even [ __ ] respect
someone like this who just does they
don't [ __ ] they don't respect you a
hundred percent they don't respect you
sorry because I just think about all
that time they these people put into
like listening their podcast assuming
their videos buying all this
pay-per-view [ __ ] it's like they just
see you as someone they're like oh these
[ __ ] morons they'll pay for it yeah
yep what the [ __ ] yep are you
ah is this that it's just that ah yeah
you know you know what I actually
couldn't believe when I was watching the
coffee silly coffee Zilla video which I
finished yesterday I couldn't believe
that k
who is very clearly pumping and dumping
every single time he dumps it all right
so at that point you have to know what
you're doing yep you're getting out
right and you could see the effect on
the price probably like in that day you
can see as soon as you dump the price
goes down a little bit so you know
you're doing something bad right why
would if you're gonna scam like that why
would you not make a separate wallet for
every [ __ ] scam you're doing yeah why
would you use the same wallet it's so
easily trackable
like I'm not saying scamming is right
I'm just saying like you have to be
levels of dumb to yeah right yeah I was
actually coffee was messaging me the
other day and he was
telling me about some of the more
you know I don't I don't want to kill
any action on anything he might be
working on but the general gist of what
he was telling me was
the capacity for fraud that is like
latent within crypto he's like is so
crazy and he kind of was screwing me a
little bit on some of the methods that
like a seasoned scammer would use in
crypto and he's like to use these
methods it takes little research if any
like you could you could discover this
right away so yeah I mean like it's just
that much more hilarious that these
dudes scam using the thing that's
supposed to anonymize and protect your
identity yeah and Trent send the ability
to track something and somehow these
guys were dumb enough to still get
tracked yeah and exposed for scamming
yeah I don't know they [ __ ]
they deserve all the [ __ ] hate I
gotta see this apology video
uh from face K I don't know how long it
is but
I just gotta see like the opening line I
know I haven't posted in a while and
there is so much that I want to say
about what's happened in the past month
but because of legal reasons all I'm
allowed to say right now is this please
please do not believe what you're
hearing online all of these people
making videos think that they know the
truth and that they know who's
responsible when they just don't so this
is the truth all right I lost money on
Save the kids token but what actually
upsets me the most is that anybody else
was hurt so we've uncovered significant
evidence which confirms that a dishonest
person abused his trust with me to scam
everybody this person gained my trust
and the trust of my friends while still
encouraging us to be the public faces of
his scheme he then abused that trust to
go and alter the code right before
launch resulting in six figure profits
for him and then leaving the rest of us
to be blamed there are lawyers who are
dealing with this manipulation and
working with authorities to make sure he
pays for what he's done and I want to
help as much as I can yeah the most
powerful thing
you know in between these takes they're
putting onions in his eyes yeah yeah
great great yeah great you nailed that
line dude let's just get a little more
just oh right all right all right and
and what was the verbiage again uh a
person who's working what person who is
has abused your trust they've abused
your trust are you ready another person
who is not me
abuse my trust dude explain your wallet
who runs your wallet man
you know what's crazy is that like when
I was like
I was like doing some calculations as
coffee as I was talking about how many
saved the kids tokens he had and what I
went back and looked at the price that
they were and I was like calculating how
much he made and I was like over a
million bucks I was like okay I get it
and then they were going through and I
realized I did my math way wrong and
they were like no these kids were making
30 to 50K on these pump and dumps which
I mean yeah I guess if you're doing like
three a month that's a lot of money
that's like we said it's like compared
to what these guys could make in as an
influencer like doing in them they use
Clan like aren't they getting brand
deals constantly that they're making
that kind of money you would think I
don't know
I I don't know
I guess it's just fast money right I
think that's all it is yeah yeah even
does that clip of rice gum on his twitch
being like I spoke to my lawyer and
he said you better get some of that six
nine energy and just start you know just
start pointing people out you know and
I'm just like
that's so lame that anyone would even
like watch that and go oh yeah that's
cool yeah yeah it's like what yeah
I mean I I guess so like Summer Rae and
I guess other people didn't hold any of
the coin they were just paid to promote
it okay
always you know still yeah kind of suss
that's the thing bro
the fact that
um this will not go away like Logan's
gonna do one and then someone will wait
a little bit and then another person
will try to do it
at what point did does it ever catch on
and people finally put two and two
together and go oh I'm getting [ __ ]
yeah
I don't know maybe there's just always
going to be that 30 percent of people
who are like
but no it's going to go back yeah what's
Dogecoin at now
30 cents or something like that
Dogecoin
price
20 cents 21 cents okay
it's going to a Dollar Man
it's going
did it
it's funny the crash happened and now
it's just like
just been down for for a long time now
right yep
I think I'm down actually a lot of money
on crypto
because I bought a bunch of ethereum
like yep like near the peak yeah it's
not how it always happens yep it always
[ __ ] happens like that